c'est la faille qu'elle racontera son
journal vous lirez l'ol
j'espère qu'elles seront chauds société
frei a remporté à la barre zimbawe sur
outils des ptic romera le petit écho de
la forêt c'est très vrai rouleur il y à
toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans le
décor de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
excusez vous recherchez l'islam est trop
drôle
attendez je vais vous lire l'article max
le corbeau a voulu saluer moi quoi vous
ressemblez à rebondir une balance mardi
mais vous êtes ridicule oui vous d'être
éduqué moi impossible y avait les pattes
quelle longueur mais pas de son longue
c'est vrai mais si je n'ai pas besoin de
monter sur une balançoire pour paraître
grandes étapes
mme lauzen de la cigogne avait visé
juste des pâtons c'est long quand cette
mode et design mais tu peux de voir si
tu veux car à ça il faut en faire
fabriquer une paire ou qu'elles
suffisent et tu es sur les conseils de
louis leur honneur max à la demande et
aux frères castors devait confectionner
des échasses
de quelle longueur les veux tu t es
chasse pliant que les pattes de
mademoiselle de la sig rien et pourquoi
un 6ème sur riddick est à côté de moi
aussi tous les deux frères questeur se
mirent tout travail et le lot 2 me max
tout fier partis se promener dans la
forêt où je ne suis pas pour je suis
fille si la fourmi on excuse moi c'est
fait mais vu de toute ma hauteur
tu peux par emile heskey puis boxe le
géo croisette au squelette au tu tiens
un caillou
ce n'est pas un caillou c'est ma carte
ou bien tard dans tosca depuis que je
suis devenu géant tout le monde paraît
ridicule map était alors à 7,3 des
lunettes triomphaux de plus belle max
continué sa promenade et oh le joli
papier
c'est ça c'est ça je suis un lapin et
toi tu es un corbeau monté en graine
mais ces toiles oui je t'avais pas
reconnu je suis si grand bastien et
l'hésitation danois grains de raisin ça
n'est pas du réseau mais s'il n'y a pas
un je vois bien tu te trompes ça n'est
que du gravier à mon peu déconfite route
même max et doyen et découvrit boris de
loups qui dégustent être un pot de miel
qu'est-ce que tu images paris une bonne
mieux en mieux
c'est mon dessert préféré à la loi par
tige est avec toi
le pouvant ce projet le pauvre géo dû
renoncer à se régaler il décida d'aller
rendre visite à mademoiselle de les
cigogneaux bonjour pathétique yeux la
mangouste rebelles hors cigogne est je
suis max nax carbo géant
mon pauvre grand comme je vous plaint
parfois parce que géants comme vous êtes
vous allé prendre froid ou à guingamp
mais si mais si vous allez attraper un
rhume qui se transformera en bronchite
qui se transformer en plo money alors
alors adieu max mais je ne veux pas
mourir dans surpris et des mois au tc
daf un bout de bois n'ont voulu mettre
le jus et puis merde vous n'avez qu'à
manger impossible avec ces maudits des
échasses attendez moi vous l'avez
déroule bien vu vous vous êtes fait mal
pour un petit big boss seulement à la
tête et j'ai compris et bien devenir
comme avant top et y est les patrons
courte mais oui match a très vite
compris qu'il ne faut pas s'être fait ou
des autres c'est ainsi qu'on se fait mal
à la tête
n'est ce pas cher téléphone
[Musique]